أجرت القوات المسلحة السويدية تدريبات مشتركة
مع فنلندا بعد أيام من تقديم
الدول طلبًا للانضمام إلى الناتو ،
تم التخطيط لهذه التدريبات قبل عامين ،
لكنها اتخذت طابعًا عاجلاً جديدًا منذ
غزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا ، أظهر الخصوم بوضوح شديد
أن العتبة لاستخدام
وسائلهم العسكرية  الوصول إلى أهدافهم وخفضت أهدافهم ،
نحن لا نستبعد أي شيء اليوم
مع الدفاعات الممولة جيدًا ، حيث يجلب كلا البلدين
الكثير إلى طاولة المفاوضات
السويد على وجه الخصوص من خلال
أجهزتها عالية التقنية محلية الصنع التي تم
إعدادها في الأصل لدعم حيادية الأمة ،
لذا فهي في الأساس
الطائرات المقاتلة ثم الغواصات ، نعم
أعتقد أن السويد لديها أربع مساهمات رئيسية ،
أعني أن الأولى هي الجغرافيا
ولا يمكن لحلف الناتو الوفاء بالسيناريو الخاص بالمادة 5
في دول البلطيق دون استخدام الأراضي السويدية ،
وثانيًا هو سلاح الجو السويدي ،
والثالث هو
التعاون الاستخباراتي العميق والرابع
إحداها هي القوة الغواصة
إذا كان جزء من غواصات الناتو
والطائرات المقاتلة يمكن أن تنطلق  أي دور أكبر
في حماية الدول الاسكندنافية وبحر البلطيق
بدون دفاع جوي سيكون من
الصعب جدًا على الجيش والبحرية
تنفيذ عملياتهما ، فنحن
قوة جوية قوية تضم 100 مقاتل
سنضيف قوة
إلى
الناتو في مبارزة  تتويج لعبة gripen jazz 39
التي صنعتها صعب ، ما هو الشعور الذي تشعر به ، نعم ، إن
وجودك في هذه الطائرة يشبه التواجد
داخل الصاروخ ، فأنت تطير شيئًا كهذا
بهذه السرعة ، إنه أمر
مدهش تمامًا باستخدام نظام إلكترونيات الطيران الخاص بنا ، وهي
طريقة جديدة تمامًا لإدارة
المعلومات ،
كل هذه المستشعرات  أعطيك الكثير من
المعلومات التي أتيحت
لي الفرصة لإلقاء نظرة داخل قمرة القيادة
وما يمكنني أن أخبرك به هو أنك
صدمت على الفور بالكم الهائل
من التكنولوجيا التي تم تعبئتها في
مساحة ضيقة جدًا
يستخدمها بالفعل أعضاء الناتو  هنغاريا في
جمهورية التشيك
، أكسبت هذه الطائرات المتطورة السويد موطنًا لما يزيد قليلاً
عن 10 ملايين شخص مكانًا بين
القوات الجوية الأعلى مرتبة في هذه
الطائرات السويدية أيضًا.  تم تصميمه ليكون قادرًا على الإقلاع
والهبوط من مدارج قصيرة جدًا ، على
سبيل المثال ، لقد مارسوا التدريب على
طريق سريع محلي ، فهم يحتاجون أيضًا إلى
عدد محدود من الأفراد للتزود بالوقود
وإعادة تسليحهم ويمكن القيام بذلك
في غضون 10 إلى 12  دقائق
إذا كان لديك قاعدة أو قاعدتان جويتان ، فأنا أعني أن
هذه ستكون أهدافًا على الفور إذا كانت
لديك تلك الإمكانية التي يمكنك من خلالها استخدام
الطرق السريعة ولإخفاء الطائرات والعمليات ، فقد
تصبح نوعًا من
عرض السويد الأقل هدفًا للحصول على عضوية الناتو قد
يكون قد حقق بعضًا غير متوقع  الاضطرابات ولكن
امتلاك هذه القدرات يمكن في
النهاية أن يساعد في كسب النقاد لأننا نجلب
المعرفة والخبرة من هذه
المنطقة التي نعيش فيها هنا ، فنحن
هنا على استعداد لمحاربة
نينا دوس سانتوس CNN في تناغم في السويد